là mais celle là ou pas je n'avais
jamais ça mais pas allez hop je vais la
mettre la chemise de carence de la
musique de karkwa là là on y est acorn
on y est oui avec quelques milliards les
yachts les nanas qui danse nue sur le
ponton elles sont là et my goal
vous connaissiez berrichon
[Musique]
c'est drôle j'aime beaucoup
attends je connais la différence quand
une couturière une anglaise mais la
couturière explique le doigt et
l'anglais s'expliquer c'est pas mal
barrés kelly à deux blocs
nb cet élégant le bloc et cet essai calé
à deux plaques
alors on pense au col à 3 à 5 ans
je t'en fait travailler des jeunes c'est
tout le jeu de palet entre les des
jeunes ses droits comme moyen lui il
avait des yeux je vais je y est ils vers
nancy travis whims images sont à quoi ça
sert de berne elle gratuite à sa vas toi
chez toi public tu dois savoir y
ramasser
[Musique]
when the rain des restos mais s'échappe
encore fait mais en même temps henry
revendu le du flan allez on y va fort
bernard plus
sont pas là voilà sans doute attention
[Musique]
quand la nuit est dû à la personne sap
en donnant un peu amer de ce soir était
chaud ou montano marimbert j'ai appris
qu'après moi c'est arithmétique
l'antenne jusqu'au bout de la nuit
et merde allez tourillon la force
obligeant les jours comme ça où les
votants sur la fin de vie sont parvenus
les roux les avis d'appels son reste
[Musique]